the Joe Rogan experience paulie's
amazing though but Polly when when he
was gonna fight that bare-knuckle I went
a little bit of rent on my me and Polly
are close man I went on a rant how
saying I don't think he should do it and
it I feel like he's punching down he's
one of the best commentators here's a
job so many people want then of course I
mean probably work together so we're
breaking down the wilder Brazil fight in
New York and there was this weird
probably in the end of this there I felt
like there's this weird kind of well of
course I mean you're telling him not to
do something that he's definitely gonna
do yeah I know
so you're resisting his idea look but if
I was doing something you don't want me
to do if you're doing something right
and we have an open conversation where
there's no weirdness like no I can't we
talked about if Polly went up to him is
like dude I'm doing it so not this [ __ ]
out didn't hopefully I get McGregor out
and also I'm just kind of bored with my
life man this could be fun for me I went
oh cool man I support you
there's no I'm not shaming him I agree
with you I feel where you're coming from
and I agree that I would want you to
tell me if you thought it was [ __ ] up
but it was a bad idea
but I think that with a guy like him you
know this is you know I don't know what
kind of options he has nobody's beating
down his door to fight him you know that
I know that Connor didn't want to fight
him he wasn't interested in that and I
don't know whether what other options
he's got for boxing but also so but then
that's when he's not the greatest
analyst in the game but he if he's gonna
fight a bare-knuckle boxing fight like
this got it he there's got to be a
financial motive for that that's I would
hope now the only thing that makes sense
is that that's a financial motive but
listen the show time pays him you know
Showtime pays him well do they what yeah
man yeah so it's like to do that you
know you look at the payday like our
tomato I think 50,000 for last fight so
let's so say they pay him triple let's
say paint quadruple let's say he's make
what is that [ __ ] $250,000 not enough
to do a bare-knuckle fight when you're
making six figures you know you could
get your face [ __ ] up too that's the
reality those knuckles man I'm changing
my tune a little bit but not all the way
you got a little tinge Oh a little bit
but here's the thing like you you do get
caught up more in bare-knuckle boxing
but you're also not kicking or using
takedowns or anything else in
bare-knuckle boxing I think it'd be way
more brutal if there's takedown
kake's because with maybe I don't think
the best guy wins also and bare-knuckle
because you know Paulie has way more
fighting experience than Artem right
Susan get more scar tissue so if there's
a guy with a ton of scar tissue your
face opens up like that
it looks like a murder scene zillion
Charles Manson murder see because of the
knuckles yeah that's cut so he might you
might land seven shots to his - but your
face is [ __ ] up especially
[Applause]